tonight a las vegas man dealing with
unimaginable grief as he deals with the
loss of three members of his immediate
family to covid19 one after the other he
tells victoria sahil he didn't think the
virus could hit so close to home
victoria joins us live in the newsroom
with really a heartbreaking story
32 year old jason rose has dealt with
more loss in the last week than most
people do in a lifetime he's struggling
to find ways to come to terms with the
loss of his grandfather grandmother and
mother he says it's just a reminder of
how quickly this virus can take away
lives don't be drinking when you are
driving i love you you better take care
jason rose now clings to the voicemails
his mom left him it hasn't even been a
week since she passed of covid my mom
couldn't barely walk like i had to carry
her down the stairs carry into my car
both of rose's grandparents and mom
started showing symptoms of covet 19 two
weeks ago a heart i kind of dropped when
my mom called and said hey we all tested
positive within a week they were in the
hospital together fighting to survive
his grandpa passed away tuesday his
grandmother died thursday then his mom
passed away friday morning just unreal
feeling knowing that
that i saw their faces every single day
and now it's like i wake up and
those faces aren't there you know three
faces gone all three of them were not
vaccinated rose's mom was a high risk
dialysis patient she was worried about
the side effects and his grandparents
relied heavily on their faith could we
have avoided it could we have done this
should we have taken the vaccine
questions rose will never have answered
at this time he and his family are
planning funeral services and also
working on saving their house his mother
bought 22 years ago her dying wish was
to hold on to that house there is a
gofundme to help with the costs that
link will be up on our website at eight
newsnow dot com reporting live from the
newsroom victoria saha 8 news now